هذا يوم عظيم بالنسبة لك بالنسبة
للرئيس ودعونا نواجه الأمر بالنسبة لبنيامين
نتنياهو و و و و حلفائه و
مؤيديه نعلم أنهم يعتقدون أن
هذا سيكون صفقة كبيرة لأنهم
قالوا ذلك لقد قالها من المنصة
ولكن  أريد أن أتناول ما
قاله الرئيس بأنه يريد أن يجعل
هذه صفقة رابحة بما في ذلك
للفلسطينيين ، هل يمكنك أن تخبرني نوعًا من التخطيط
الدقيق للمكان الذي تعتقد فيه أن الفوز هو
للفلسطينيين ، التفاصيل الدقيقة
مثالية أولاً  كل ما أود أن
أقوله إن اليوم كان إنجازًا
كبيرًا للرئيس ترامب ، وهو الشيء الذي
كان بإمكانه فقط القيام به ، حيث التقى أمس
برئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ولكن أيضًا مع
الجنرال غانز خصمه في وقت
السياسات المثيرة للانقسام في إسرائيل حيث
يمكنهم '  لا أوافق كثيرًا على أنه جمع
البلد معًا حول
أكثر القضايا إثارة للانقسام ، ما فعله أيضًا
هو أننا أصدرنا
خطة تفصيلية من 80 صفحة في الخطط السابقة التي كان لديك فيها
مبادرة السلام العربية وهي مهمة
جدًا  جهد جيد يتكون من ثمانية
أسطر ثم كان لديك مقترحات
سابقة كانت من صفحتين إلى ثلاث صفحات من
وثائق الكلمات التي تتحدث حقًا عن
مبادئ عليا ، كما
جعل إسرائيل توافق لأول مرة على دولة
وجعل إسرائيل توافق على خريطة لذلك
ما رأيته اليوم هو أن الرئيس
ترامب بنى الكثير من الثقة مع
دولة إسرائيل ، لقد فعل الكثير من
الأشياء العظيمة التي جعلت إسرائيل أكثر أمانًا
والعلاقة بين أمريكا
وإسرائيل أقوى وما استطاع
أن يفعله اليوم هو  قدم
للفلسطينيين طريقًا إلى دولة
وأرض متجاورة وظروفًا
حيث يمكنهم شق طريقهم إلى
استقلالهم كرامتهم كل هذه
الأشياء المختلفة جنبًا إلى جنب مع خطة اقتصادية بقيمة 50 مليار
دولار يمكن أن
تجعلهم دولة مزدهرة للغاية في
المستقبل.  إنها فرصة كبيرة
للفلسطينيين وأنت تعلم أن لديهم
سجلًا مثاليًا
في استغلال كل فرصة أتيحت لهم في
ماضيهم ولكن ربما
ستقرأ القيادة تفاصيلها
وتوقف عن المواقف وستفعل ما هو أفضل
لمحاولة تحسين حياة الشعب الفلسطيني
أعتقد أنني أريد أن أسألك لأنه من
الواضح أن الرئيس نفسه
قال الرئيس ترامب أنك تعلم أننا سننتظر لنرى
ما يقوله العالم العربي  لأن ما
سيقولونه هو أنك تعرف أهمية كبيرة
من حيث كيفية حدوث ذلك ، فقد
كان
من الملاحظ أنه في غرفة البيت الأبيض
في حفل البيت الأبيض لم
يكن هناك سوى سفير عمان
والإمارات والبحرين.  أن
الفلسطينيين قد رفضوا وأن
الأردنيين قد أصدروا بالفعل
بيانًا يمكنني أن أقرأ أجزاء منه
لكم إلى أين يذهب هذا بعد ذلك جيدًا ، ما
الذي تعتقد أنه سيحدث بعد ذلك
لأنه لم يكن هناك
دعم علني من أصحاب الثقل
في  العالم العربي إذا نظرت إلى
ما فعله الرئيس ترامب في المنطقة
بشكل عام ، فقد وحد المنطقة حول
أهداف مشتركة وأعداء مشتركين ،
لذا فإن ما تمكنا من تحقيقه هو الحصول على
الناس للتركيز على إيران وسلوكهم الخبيث من
خلال وضع خانق على مواردهم
المالية ، لقد أوقفنا الكثير من
تمويل الإرهاب عندما وصل الرئيس ترامب إلى
هنا حيث كان لداعش خلافة
بحجم بلدنا وقد دمرها
وقتلهم للتو.  الزعيم
البغدادي وهو يعمل مع المملكة العربية السعودية
والعديد من الدول الأخرى
لمكافحة التطرف والأيديولوجية ، لذا فإن
ما نراه من الكثير من
البلدان الأخرى هو أنهم سعداء للغاية
لأن هناك أخيرًا جهد حقيقي
على  هناك خطة حقيقية مطروحة على
الطاولة لعرض حقيقي وأن الرئيس
ترامب كان قادرًا على ضمان
إدراكهم أنه لم يكن بإمكان أي رئيس آخر
تحقيق ذلك ،
وهم يأملون
أن يفعل الفلسطينيون شيئًا عقلانيًا لمرة واحدة.
طاولة المفاوضات ، وبالتالي فإن الشروط
ليست شروطًا نهائية ، فهذا
عرض افتتاحي وإذا جاء الفلسطينيون
ولديهم بعض التعديلات ، فإنهم يريدون
تغيير الخط الذي يريدون تغييره.
الجمل يريدون التفاوض على
أشياء مختلفة ، ستكون هناك مرونة
إذا كان هذا بالفعل أساسًا للمفاوضات
والفلسطينيون قبلوا العرض وجاءوا إلى الولايات
المتحدة أو حاولت الإدارة
التفاوض ، تعلمون أن هذا شيء واحد لذلك
أريد  أن أسألك ، ثم أطلق عليها اسم
خريطة مفاهيمية وسميت هذا
أساسًا للمفاوضات
صرح رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي أنه في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
سيفرض قوانين دولة
إسرائيل ، تلك هي الكلمات التي تخرج من
فمه على الأردن.  يقع الوادي في تلك
المناطق في الضفة الغربية ، وهو يسميه
يهودا والسامرة حيث توجد
مستوطنات وأماكن أخرى من هذا القبيل
ويفترض أن يكون فوق القدس أيضًا أو
لا أعرف عن القدس الشرقية ولكن
مع ذلك إذا حدث ذلك في نهاية هذا
الأسبوع فذلك مع  موافقة
الولايات ، نعم لا أعتقد أن
هذا سيحدث في نهاية هذا الأسبوع على الأقل ليس بقدر
ما أعرف ولكن مرة أخرى ، فإن الكثير من هذه المجالات
فقط هو الواقع هو أن
إسرائيل  وريث ولم يغادروا
، لم تكن هناك صفقة أبدًا حيث
فكروا في القيام بذلك وهي ليست
عملية ، فأنا لا أنظر إلى العالم
كما كان في عام 1967 ، فأنا أنظر إلى
العالم كما هو موجود في عام 2020 لديك  خمسة
ملايين فلسطيني محاصرون حقًا
بسبب القيادة السيئة ، لذا فإن
ما فعلناه هو أننا خلقنا
فرصة لقيادتهم
إما أن تنتهز أو لا تنتهز
هذه الفرصة إذا أفسدوا هذه الفرصة التي لديهم مرة أخرى
مسارًا مثاليًا  سجل
الفرص الضائعة إذا أفسدوا هذا
الأمر ، أعتقد أنهم سيواجهون صعوبة بالغة في
النظر إلى المجتمع الدولي
في وجهه قائلين إنهم
ضحايا قائلين إن لديهم حقوقًا ، وهذا يمثل
قدرًا كبيرًا بالنسبة لهم إذا
جاؤوا إلى طاولة المفاوضات  والتفاوض أعتقد
أنه يمكنهم الحصول على شيء ممتاز